salut romain et 10 dont tu savais que
pour améliorer la qualité de tes
érection il suffit de plonger
entièrement dans un grand bain d'uriné
fraîche non banon fake
[Musique]
on va démarrer cette nouvelle saison et
parce que comme romain vous a sûrement
raconter n'importe quoi sur votre santé
on va démonter quelques mythes et
quelques mytho allez c'est parti
quand on arrache les cheveux blancs il
en repousse 2 quand on arrache les
cheveux c'est un choix de la même
couleur qui repousse c'est à dire que
l'on est beau gosse alors toi brecel
quand on arrache un cheveux foncés c'est
un cheveux foncés qui repousse et si on
arrache un cheveu blanc est ce qui
repousse un cheveu blanc attention un
seul parce que quand on arrache les
cheveux on le retire de son follicules
et dans chaque follicules il ya un
cheveu pas deux ni trois ni pour par
donc ne fait pas ça les cheveux arrachés
à force ça finit par ne pas retoucher
vous risqueriez de vous retrouver poivre
et chauffe quand même s'infecter wavre
[Musique]
l'alcool un réchaud un petit coup de
gnôle en cas de blizzard tout le monde
fait ça d'ailleurs les saint bernard
dans leurs tonneaux autour du cou du
diabolo pêche prison en vérité l'alcool
ça provoque une vasodilatation c'est à
dire une dilatation des vaisseaux et
notamment ceux à la surface de la peau
c'est ce qui donne cet aspect rougeau
qui est encore est au moins au début
et c'est aussi ce qui fait augmenter la
température de la peau ça donne une
sensation de chaleur mais ça disparaît
quand les vaisseaux entraîne leur taille
normale et ça fait même perdre de la
chaleur au corps donc ça à l'effet
exactement inverse à celui espéré ya
même un risque d'hypothermie
mauvaise idée oubliée la masturbation
rend sourd on a déjà parlé toujours pas
à les faire craquer ses doigts c'est
dangereux
ok le bruit peut faire grincer des dents
mais en réalité c'est sans danger dans
nos articulations il ya un liquide
visqueux qui appelait le liquide
synovial ac est chargé de lait lubrifié
jamais vous et aussi de nourrir les
cartilages dans ce liquide via des
bulles de gaz qui peuvent se former
notamment quand on titille ses doigts ça
s'appelle la cavitation les variations
pression font exploser les bulles c'est
ce qui provoque ce fameux bruit est
complètement inoffensive et ça provoque
pas d'arthrose non plus donc vous pouvez
y aller sauf si ça février vos voisins
ce n'est pas cruel les épinards en forme
désolé de faire de la peine mais pop et
les épinards c'est bon pour la santé et
pour les muscles mais ça a jamais
transformer un vieux marin pourri en
superman un moyen d'ailleurs les
épinards c'est pas si riche en fer quand
le prétend on raconte que cette croyance
viendrait de l'erreur d'un biochimiste
allemands nommés et milram wolf
ils se seraient trompés en plaçant une
virgule pendant ces recherches qui
aurait multiplié par dix la véritable
teneur en fer des épinards même cette
histoire on n'est pas sûr que ce soit
pas du pipeau par contre ce dont on est
sûr c'est du fer y en a plus dans les
lentilles dans les huîtres ou dans les
abats vous fait une grimace il ya un
coup devant vous pouvez rester bloqué
sérieux regarder la télé de trop près à
abîme les regarder la télé trop près ça
peut entraîner une fatigue visuelle de
m'accueillir dans l'obscurité ça peut
donner un peu mal à la tête mais dans
les deux cas aucune étude n'a démontré
que ça nuisait à l'acuité visuelle
en fait si quelqu'un regarde la télé
aura de l'écran c'est peut-être parce
qu'il est mieux mais c'est juste un bon
moyen de s'en rendre compte qu'à pas de
lien de causalité
par contre regarder la télé trop près ça
peut déclencher des crises dont souffre
d'épilepsie photosensible et ça on en a
déjà parlé je ne suivais pas content
après allongé il faut attendre deux
heures avant de se baigner un malaise en
rentrant dans l'eau ça peut arriver ici
on fait un malaise dans l'eau où peut se
noyer même s'il ya pas beaucoup de
profondeur
ça arrive notamment quand on rentre dans
une eau froide juste après avoir eu très
chaud c'est ce qu'on appelle une
hydrocution et la digestion n'a rien à
voir là dedans et se baigner juste après
avoir mangé ça ne provoque pas de
l'hydrocution alors bien sûr si vous
avez mangé trois choucroute et 4
cassoulet d'un coup à midi le tout
arrosé de 12 litres de vin rouge allait
peut-être pas vous m'aidiez tout de
suite même deux heures ça risque de
faire mieux mais pour tous les autres
vous pouvez y aller voilà vous avez
compris c'est pas parce que tout le
monde le dit que c'est forcément vrai
alors quand on vous parle de votre santé
méfiez vous de votre confiance attention
il s'agit pas de devenir parano juste de
garder sa curiosité et son esprit
critique quand il s'agit de votre santé
ou tout le reste ne serait ce que parce
que la médecine est pas une science
exacte est considéré aujourd'hui comme
une vérité ça va peut-être être démontée
devant encore une nouvelle étude
alors n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner et
à vous mettre à jour d'ailleurs je vous
propose quelque chose pour cette
nouvelle saison de dtc je vais tâcher de
répondre régulièrement à des questions
vous posez que ce soit pour vérifier les
croyances comme on vient de le faire
pour expliquer des phénomènes que vous
ne comprenez pas conserve la santé le
corps humain ou les malades j'ai aussi
envie de sortir de mon cabinet pour
aller tester des trucs sur le terrain ça
peut être n'importe quoi des techniques
de récupération
un aide des soins du matériel médical ou
tout autre sauce qui vous titille
n'hésitez pas à me proposer des fruits
et pendant mon absence assez les mines
qui gardera la maison et ouais s'appelle
les n'y voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui mais c'est reparti pour une
saison
posez-moi des questions dans les
commentaires dites moi ce que vous avez
envie de me voir tester on se retrouvent
vendredi pour une surprise
ici la porte
[Musique]